you can be healthy and still be invaded
by the demons in your mind
like the fear of fear can still become
an oppressive
stifling force in your life you can you
can be living in
in in in constant gnawing aggravation
with a ptsd
like filter that that that you meet the
world with
everything is something that can hurt
you i mean
literally that's that's the wiring of a
traumatized person of a vigilant person
i mean they don't feel safe in their
body
so if there's not something to worry
about outside they'll start worrying
about
[ __ ] inside and the only thing that
apparently can cure people of that
miswired nervous system is something
like mdma psychotherapy something that
allows for fear extinction memory
reconsolidation something that
that allows for somatic healing and
cognitive re-patterning
you know drop back into your body and
relearn what it's like to be in your
body without fear
again easier said than done because the
[ __ ] trauma runs deep
the imprint runs deep and and it's
resilient
and it's resilient mdma it doesn't
matter how deep it runs
exactly exactly we'll face it
it doesn't matter how deep the trauma
you can be you can be
you have you have been yeah you could
have been the person who have
experienced
auschwitz yeah you're still going to be
healed with mdma
right but but the thing about mdma
psychotherapy is you can do the drug
you can do the therapy you can do the
integration and you might have the
afterglow for two weeks
or even six months but eventually old
patterns resurface
and you relapse back into old patterns
of neuroticism
often they emerge from the sunken place
so you didn't expect to go to bed
anxious but then your nervous system
started to feel off and then your mind
accompanies your nervous system and
before you know it those negative
thoughts and that hypervigilant has
changed your physiology and now you
can't sleep well i think
it's uh you know what people need to get
familiar with this consciousness
this uh primal consciousness which which
is the watcher which is like which is
the one who sees what's going on like
all
the thoughts let's say are clouds moving
through your head you know
these uh all these loops or whatever
emerges inside of you or whatever
identification or whatever
uh it's it you always identify you
if you identify yourself with the
watcher with the with
this you have the separation from you
uh then then then you don't get
carried away in these destructive uh
loop pattern
of uh mental uh place that's right
that's right
and that's the medicine that
hasn't fully uh
[Music]
spread throughout my body like it hasn't
fully seeped in like i haven't fully
learned that lesson like i
it's not second nature i don't have the
training you know
i i identify with the suffering anxious
soul
or have been at least for more than i
like to admit
you know like i'm a creative person that
gets into flow but i
[ __ ] have battled my neurotic demons
like i have
i have wrestled with those you know
negatively pre-configured thought
patterns of imminent death or fear or
something to worry about around the
corner
oh yeah bro i know that space well
that's why the next time i get a
girlfriend we're going to
mdma four times a year it's gonna be
part of our relationship
we're gonna fall in love and we're gonna
like ritualistically have a sacred mdma
session four times a year
sometimes with a therapist there
sometimes by ourselves we'll create a
magic circle
we'll get into that holy space that womb
with the view consciousness ready for
imprinting
and we'll dance together we'll make love
together and we'll do eye gazing
together and we'll set intentions
together
and we'll read each other love letters
right and then we'll listen to our
favorite songs together and we'll cry
together while listening to our favorite
songs together and sometimes it'll be
oldies like the beatles we'll sing along
to let it be
or we'll sing along to crimson and
clover and other times it'll be like
ceremonial more instrumental type of
music that'll transport us into this
like
wild domain you know beyond beyond the
doors of perception whatever it may be
we will we will practice intersubjective
safety
being naked vulnerable and unafraid
together and learn to trust and learn to
heal
that's what i have to like build into my
future romantic relationships because
otherwise i fear
[Music]
well otherwise i fear that that um
you know that that'll default to a state
of
suffering um for
a a you know for too much of a
too large of a percentage of a mental
experience
so can a relationship provide
essentially eventually
healing from one's neuroses you know i
know they say you're not supposed to say
does love save or can love save or
pharmacologically enhanced love
interactions
save but they say that they're not
supposed to but i still think they can i
think you can find a partner
and i think that together you guys can
be like okay well let's um
let's be each other's um martyrs and
saviors
do you know does that make sense like
let's let's just okay like
you know let's let's let's let's play
out
archetypal mythos
uh together you know let's set the stage
and let's you know let's come alive and
let's purge and
die and cry and reconciliate you know
that's what i let's the pathway of
healing through love
and and pharmacology i want to take us
to
no like